what's up believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Elon Musk level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world instead of help
you on your journey today we're going to
look at Elon Musk and his views on the
danger of artificial intelligence and
alien life-forms enjoyed a lot of
experts in AI don't share the same level
of concern do you do about the danger of
fools what what's his last words which
is what specifically do you believe that
they don't well the biggest issue I see
with so-called AI experts is that they
they think they know more than they do
and they think they're smarter than they
actually are in general we are all much
smarter than we think we are but much
less smart you've dumber than we think
you are by a lot so this is this tends
to play plague smart people that you
just can't they define themselves by
their intelligence and they they don't
like the idea that a machine could be
way smarter than them so they just count
the idea which is fundamentally flawed
that's the wishful thinking in a
situation I'm really quite close to I'm
very close to the cutting edge in AI and
it scares the hell out of me it's
capable of vastly more than almost
anyone knows and the rate of improvement
is exponential but you can see that some
things like alphago which went from in
the span of maybe six to nine months it
went from being unable to beat even a
reasonably good go player so then
beating the European world champion who
was ranked 600 then beating Lisa doll
for five what would be in a world
champion for many years then beating the
current world champion then beating
everyone
well thanks Immelt aeneas Li then then
there was alpha zero which crushed
alphago a hundred to zero
and alpha zero just learnt by playing
itself and it can play basically any
game that you put the rules in for if
you whatever rules you give it just
literally read the rules play the game
every superhuman for any game nobody
expected that rate of improvement if you
asked those so those same experts who
think AI is not progressing at the rate
that I'm saying I think you'll find that
their predictions for things like go and
and other and other AI advancements have
their true their batting average is
quite weak it's not good that we'll see
this also with with self-driving I I
think probably by Anna make sure the
self-driving will be well encompass
essentially all modes driving and be at
least a hundred to two hundred percent
safer than a person by the end of next
year we're talking maybe eighteen months
from now
Natsuko study on on Tesla's autopilot
version one which is relatively
primitive and found that it was a forty
five percent reduction in highway
accidents and that's despite or two
pilot one being just version one version
two I think will be at least two or
three times better that's the current
version that's running right now so the
rate of improvement is really dramatic
we have to figure out some way to ensure
that the advent of digital super
intelligence is one which is symbiotic
with humanity I think that's the single
biggest existential crisis that we face
and the most pressing one and how do we
do that I mean if we take it that it's
inevitable at this point that some
version of AI is coming down the line
how do we how do we steer through them
well I'm not normally an advocate of
regulation and oversight I mean I think
it's once you generally go inside
minimizing those things but this is a
case where you have a very serious
danger to the public
and therefore there needs to be a public
body that has insight and then oversight
on to confirm that everyone is
developing AI safely this is extremely
important I think a danger of AI is much
greater than the danger of nuclear
warheads landlocked
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just both nuclear warheads if
they want that would be insane and mark
my words
AI is far more dangerous than nukes far
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
which question you've been asking for a
long time I think it's a question that's
coming to the forefront over the last
year where you begin to realize that it
doesn't necessarily I think if we we've
all been focused in on the idea of
artificial superintelligence right which
is clearly a danger but maybe you know a
little further out what's happened over
the last years you've seen artificial
what I would be calling artificial
stupidity talk about you know
algorithmic manipulation of social media
like we're in it now it's starting it's
starting to happen how do we how do we
is it
what's the intervention at this point
I'm not really all that worried about
the short-term stuff things that are
okay but like narrow AI is not a species
level risk it will it will result in
dislocation in lost jobs and you know
that didn't sort of better weaponry and
that kind of thing but it is not a
fundamental species level risk whereas
digital super intelligence is so it's
really all about laying the groundwork
to make sure that if humanity
collectively your science that creating
digital super intelligence is the right
move then we should do so very very
carefully very very carefully
this is the most important thing that we
could possibly do you know I think one
of the most troubling questions is
artificial intelligence and I don't mean
narrow AI like a vehicle autonomy I
would put in the narrow AI class
it's narrowly trying to achieve a
certain function but deep artificial
intelligence or what are sometimes
called
artificial general intelligence where
you can have AI that is much much much
smarter than the smartest human on earth
this I think it is a dangerous situation
why it is dangerous I mean there is to
view one view is the artificial
intelligent will help humanity there is
another school of think of thought is
artificial intelligent this is a threat
to humanity why is it I think it's both
you know it's it's like one way to think
of it is imagine we're going to be
visited you imagine you're very
confident that we were going to be
visited by super intelligent aliens in
let's say ten years or twenty years at
the most super intelligence so you think
within 20 years yeah so have alien in
earth ha ha well digital super
intelligence will be like an alien it
will be like yeah but but my question is
do you think there is other intelligent
life outside there it seems probable but
I think this is this is one of the great
questions in physics and philosophy is
where are the aliens maybe they're among
us I don't know
some people think I'm an alien not true
but true but maybe we are a course that
said when we are alien and then I mean
if you look at this part of the world
yeah they believe that human being are
not from Earth they came from somewhere
else evie an atom came from somewhere
else to act so in a way human being
alien to this land do you think will
make contact with alien within the next
50 years well that's a really tough one
to say okay if there are super
intelligent aliens out there they're
probably already observing us that would
seem quite likely and we just are not
smart enough to realize it but I can do
some some back of the envelope
calculations and any advanced alien
civilization that that was at all
interested in populating the galaxy even
without without exceeding the speed of
light even if you're only moving at say
10 or 20 percent of the speed of light
you could populate the entire galaxy and
let's say 10 million years maybe 20
million years max this is nothing you
know in the grand scheme of things thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this is a new test series that
we're putting together on trending
topics from successful entrepreneurs I'd
love to know what did you think should
we continue to the series do you have
other ideas that you'd love to see put
it in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon if you tell yourself a story long
enough you start to believe it
you believe you act like I have Tulsa
what a wail out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 4 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250 4
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access